- This is a very exciting moment for me.
My life is all shit, fires, and issues.
So for Tyler to say this
is a good one, I'm excited.
CEO of (bleep) or (bleep)?
Amazing.
(laughing)
We'll be beeping two of the words in there
but it went well, it was good.
(hip-hop music)
(phone ringing)
So do you wanna focus on
that part of my career,
like why I thought I was able to go from
being a wine retailer into kind of
this media thing I've become?
When it comes to business
I've always been fearless.
I didn't start swimming until I was nine.
I was scared of dogs
pretty much my whole life.
I don't like heights all that much.
I'm scared of snakes like,
I'm not trying to tackle them,
I have no interest in
hanging around with snakes.
I think everybody's got their
strengths and weaknesses.
When it comes to business,
boy have I been fearless my whole life.
Sometimes people wait
until their parents die
so they can run the business, you know?
I went a different route.
I wanted to give back to my parents,
I built the business for them
and I then I checked that box
and took my skills elsewhere.
I will say this, I think
the surrounding neighborhoods
of Manhattan have a thing.
When you're in the heart of it right,
the heart of the world,
I mean New York City is
literally, literally, maybe,
arguably the most important
city in the world.
You know when you're within miles of that,
you feel that heartbeat but
you're still not it, right?
So you have a little bit of
that chip on your shoulder
and there's a little bit
of that bridge and tunnels,
a little bit of like,
you're the second tier
of the ultimate A tier.
I'll be honest with you, I think that is a
disproportionate advantage.
I think it's the most
similar thing to actually
being an immigrant in America.
You know, it's having that
little bit of hunger and chip
and then if you're lucky
enough to be an immigrant
and grow up in Jersey,
I think it's an edge.
I think it's an intensity,
a vibe, a comet,
a level of common sense,
it's an awareness.
Yeah, I think it's a really,
pretty special thing.
Embrace the chip on your shoulder
and expand on it and triple down on it
and really use it to your advantage.
Awesome, you're welcome,
take care, bye-bye.
- I have one more question
that I've been wondering.
Who would you say that
besides I guess family members
has been your biggest role model?
- Nobody.
- Nobody?
- That's the truth.
- No one's ever like
inspired you to do something?
- I'm sure, but I can't figure it out.
The real answer--
- 'Cause you're trying to figure it out
or something you've just
kind of, have accepted?
- Like do you know who, you know who,
because they're not,
it's not like I've ever
spent any thoughtful time in saying
Richard Branson did this or
I've just never done that.
Like kindness and compassion
and empathy and gratitude
and good guys and girls inspire me,
like oh that's a nice
person, that's a good dude,
that gets me going and then the market.
Like everybody.
Like the game.
The game, the market, the process.
But I've never really, you know?
- You seen that video
of Matthew McConaughey,
like my role model is like me in 10 years?
Like that's kind of--
- That's interesting, I
kinda, that's interesting.
- You try to be yourself in 10 years
and when you get there,
obviously you're not--
- That's cool.
That's a better articulation probably.
- Yeah, that's how I kind of--
- I'm very insular, like really insular.
Like really, like I don't
even know about people.
You know?
Like the thought to
take time to do homework
on somebody that I admire
is like going to outer space.
- You also have to do the
homework, like you said
building relationships,
you have to kind of
know the people that you're meeting.
- Yeah but I treat, notice
it's a good microcosm
back to the (bleep) thing.
You're right but I'm agnostic.
I'm basically talking
to you as hard as I'd be
talking to my next meeting
which is Wladimir Klitschko.
Which is true, literally
Wladimir Klitschko
is walking in right now
but I'm not gonna try
any harder, it's just the same.
- I respect that.
- Yeah it ended up being a
great attribute in hindsight.
- And you find that people respect that?
Like they don't--
- I think people subconsciously feel it.
I think big name people
realize I don't give a fuck
and I think people on the
coming up appreciate it.
- That makes sense.
It's like they've been treated
like royalty their entire life--
- It's a competitive advantage,
it's a competitive vantage, you know?
The thing for me is
like I just don't care.
I do the right thing at the
right moment every time--
- And if they're not about
it, just on with them?
- Yeah 'cause I don't think
anybody's gonna do anything for me.
- Yeah that's true.
- I have zero expectations
and I can get everything by myself.
- Did you always think that?
- Yeah.
- I feel like at the
beginning, it's a lot of like
you do everything for yourself.
- Don't forget, I had a lot of advantages.
I was a bad student, I didn't
grow up in a big time family,
so I had a lot of advantages
because I didn't know the alternative.
- Yeah that's true.
- I didn't know what the Hamptons were.
I didn't know what, oh you
go to an Ivy League school
or a good school or fuck,
if I knew that shit,
I should've at least did
a little bit just for,
if it was just Michigan,
Wisconsin, or Indiana right,
I woulda been like oh,
(laughing)
I didn't even know that meant anything.
I was in a such an
immigrant, insular cocoon
in my own head, in my own little family,
I didn't even do like
extracurricular activities,
it was just insular.
It was super weird.
- When did you say you figured that out?
- The last 10 years.
I'm like, oh that's why
it's good to go to Penn.
You know, like your roommate
might be fuckin', you know?
- Yeah.
That's very true.
- Like I didn't know.
That's given me an unbelievable advantage.
(upbeat music)
Rumors are that, there was no music.
- [D-Rock] I didn't use
the Airport Gary music.
- Why would you not use
the Airport Gary music
when I'm turning into Airport Gary?
(upbeat music)